what was the story when you know early
on i i mean i don't remember the time
frame but when letterman left to go do
cbs do i have it right that you were the
guy the network was considered not conan
o'brien they wanted you to take over the
letterman slot that's what i heard and
all nbc
on nbc that's what i always heard now
there was a there was a process
uh what happened was
they ran like almost like an audition
process
and they got it down to like i don't
know ten people five ten people
and i was one of those people
uh and they brought i think they brought
us all out to los angeles to perform at
the improv in los angeles it might have
been lorne michaels i think he was part
of that selection group and i can't
remember exactly who was even on the
bill that night it might have been like
drew carey and paul provenza and some
other folks
uh
and we performed stand-up on there and
it was kind of the final
uh
round of the auditions
and then ultimately i think
it kind of ended there none of us i
don't think did test shows except for
like i think conan did some test shows
and then that was it i'll tell you one
thing i was up on back in that whole
leno era before
conan took over the tonight show jeff
zucker had me out to dinner and told me
he wanted me to guest host the tonight
ship to be their permanent guest host
and i was like does jayla i don't know
about this he's like absolutely he loves
the idea and as it turned out like no he
didn't know what happened and he didn't
love the idea and you were [ __ ]
making the whole thing up and i just
we still i talked to james about it uh
dixon and we're always like what the
[ __ ] was that dinner that was the
weirdest [ __ ] dinner wow yeah it's so
weird you know what else yeah here you
are a guy they're considering maybe as a
takeover for letterman and then they
want to see you do stand up
and and what has that got to do with you
taking over letterman i think they just
wanted to kind of get a sense of you
know what the [ __ ] knows what's a real
audition for a talk show other than like
you do it and everybody sucks at it like
for the first six months like it's it's
a
it's an art form it's it's the thing
that you perfected over all those years
and you never really know and then and
and look conan was not really a
performer he wasn't a stand-up or
anything but man he created like a very
iconic and unique kind of show because
those shows are [ __ ] reductive and
they're basically
a copy of another show and it's very
hard to do something original well you
know makes a good point about you as a
performer in a way thank god none of
that worked out because that forced you
to go to comedy central and develop a
whole new format i don't think anyone
was doing anything like the daily show i
think like well the daily show existed
you know they built a nice car we were
able to modify it a little bit to our to
our liking and uh and take it into the
other direction but it's like music to a
large extent there's influences and all
kinds of different things and so
you know
you can always trace it back and go
there's a little stern in this there's a
little carson in this there's a little
smothers brothers there's a little bit
of hopefully carlin so you know it's all
those people that you admired and
hopefully that influence
gets to percolate kind of in your own in
your own sauce
and you come out with something that is
unique to what you do i always said that
on the show we'll know when we're
succeeding when we do things that could
only happen here
[Music]
you